have paid more attention to why didn't
you ever look for like just a normal guy
with like a nine to five
because it's just guys will always say
like pay attention to what they do not
what they say
and okay and it's like a lot of times
we'll complain about getting like
cheated on or something right and then
you know we Overlook the nine to five
guy who won't
I would say that I mean the my first
boyfriend I met in college he was
regular guy and I loved him to death
um I had I had dated a lawyer during
that during that span to broke up with
who college guy um I broke up with him
because it got abusive on both ends but
this is this is just just from the guy's
perspective like they're they're gonna
be like okay well that was the guy who
wouldn't cheat but you dumped him well
it got to a place where he was very kind
I mean he was condescending and
emotionally really abusive and then it
got to a place where you're pushing me
now you're bruising up my arms and now
I'm putting my hands on you because I'm
trying to defend myself and I just felt
like the respect was gone
um it didn't have nothing to do with
whether he cheated or not it was we are
we are very toxic together and I do not
foresee us moving past this like I feel
like once this is me once that respect
is lost for whatever reason and then I
all put your hands on each other it has
to end because there's only one way it's
going to end it only gets progressively
worse in my opinion in my experience I'm
not trying to find out either you're
putting your hands on me doing all the
other stuff I don't want to see what
you're capable of did you file a police
report at all or no
no
because again it's just like from
like a lot of times we'll say these
things about guys but it's like it's the
question it's like me if I'm getting
punched in the face I I oh I wasn't
getting punched in the face it was more
so you were like bruising my arms and
pushing me down and little stuff like
that and I I know I if he would have
punched me in the face that would have
also be a different thing I've never
been hitting or punched anything ever so
yeah I feel like it was leading up to
being punched in the face
um but bruises on my arms to me is a
little more than enough and then you
never hit first I slapped him yeah okay
okay but you would agree that's like
mutually abusive no that's what I said I
said yeah I never said oh my God no like
it got to a place where I'm like all
right now I'm about to put my hands on
YouTube and that's the thing like I
think
a lot of times you actually do you know
agree with like a lot of the stuff I say
which is interesting why
um
I was expecting to just
yeah on some level but no you actually
are
more bass than I thought you were gonna
be I I like what you talk about I think
that it's foreign to me because or I
would say probably a lot of females as
well because
I I can honestly say I speak for myself
because I want to speak for everybody
but I never thought about it I never
thought about how men feel I never
thought about biologically speaking what
makes sense I never thought about how in
marriage you know especially if the man
makes more that it's kind of a shitty
contract on there and I know business
that doesn't make sense you know unless
we're signing prenups right so it's just
like
since I've been listening to your
contents and I knew I was going to get
on here I started to like you a lot more
right it's easy to just kind of take a
clip from you and be like oh my God she
said she's that I personally like you
like your personality is why I got on a
seven hour flight and I knew that even
though I may not agree and I think that
and not even about agreeing even though
I may not just limit it to just that
like that perspective I respect it and I
think it's true there's a there's really
not a lot of stuff I think is untrue and
I just have told you even when we were
speaking off camera that
this is a newer mentality I don't know
what this mentality would mean to a
society as a whole we kind of talked
about the arranged marriages and um uh
what would that mean for society as a
whole right and I think I can't remember
the verbage you used when we were
talking about how um the arranged
marriages and how women um if we had
dreams and stuff we wanted to explore on
what what that outcome would look like
you said that I don't remember the term
you used though okay
um but no it's like I I get it and all I
can do is just be honest about
like this is the expression that
I like that is coded within me and I am
willing to accept the consequences that
comes behind it so I don't ask for
um
people to look at me through a different
lens
um I'm just kind of here to be myself
and just showcase another perspective
that's really it
so
I'm thinking so you do the
looking back was there anything that you
would do differently and is there a
different advice that you would give to
a 20 year old girl that has the same
opportunities that you did
I think the biggest thing that I would
want to do differently is what were the
athletes
well I will say
um
I have to be honest with myself because
I think it's easy to take the cliche
route and say like I would do nothing
differently now from the
wisdom I have acquired no I would not
change this wisdom for a clean slate and
that's just the god honest truth but I
will say to 20 year olds and even to my
20 year old self
I hate how I allowed myself to just be
like used up I meant
and that came from a lack of self-worth
I did not understand my value that I was
born with I didn't and I gave
again people look at sex differently but
sex is spiritual unification at the end
they don't care how you spin it it's
spiritual women okay that's okay
whatever okay fine for women it's
spiritual unification
and people that I shared my body with
when I think about my list
it's repulsive because they didn't
deserve it
but that was an outcome of me
discounting my worth and
it's disgusting
um
I hate even having that
spiritual tie in any type of way but
yeah I would absolutely change sexually
how I move around and not even
necessarily because of like the societal
outcome it's more so
it makes you like feel yeah it doesn't
feel good
knowing that you gave a sacred part of
you to a man that looked at sex with you
as taking a piss
that's not fulfilling it's disgusting to
think about and I
feel like I've beat myself up every
single day for my decisions and what
people say about me online holds no
candle to what I've told myself on a
daily basis like there's I've been
called worse by better and that better
be me like I have talked down to myself
and I felt like I was unworthy for a
very long time and I would say this is
more of a recent awareness like for the
past year
um
where I'm like
Britney you were always enough like you
never had to seek validation outside of
you you never had to look that far and
um that's what I would would tell myself
I would and try to tell women
you should really think about who you're
laying down with like and that's that is
a more traditional view but it's like
sex is not even worth it if they don't
give a [ __ ] about you they don't care
about you they have no desire to they
don't want to know your favorite color
they don't give a [ __ ] so why do you
want them over top of you again that's
come from
feeling used up and sometimes that's why
the used Goods comments they sting
because you know what
there are times I felt like that I feel
like the old toy or sorry the new toy
that now is unexciting and put away in a
box as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible